Hello everyone. Welcome to a new episode of The
Dissenter. I'm your host, as always, Ricardo Lops, and
today I'm joined by a fellow YouTuber, Caroline Kraf.
She's the YouTuber behind Crafty Thinking, where she applies
philosophy to modern topics so that you understand why
people believe what they believe. And today we're going
to talk about the different takes that people have.
On sex work because Carolyn has done recently a
video on feminist perspectives on sex work and she
also done an interview about it. So we're, and
I of course have an ongoing series on my
channel called Humanizing Sex Workers. So that's what we're
going to talk about today. So Carolyn, welcome to
the show. It's a big pleasure to
everyone. Yeah, thank you for having me. I'm glad
to be here. I think this is a really
interesting topic, so I'm excited to talk to someone
about it.
Yeah, me too. I've been exploring it for a
few years now, so, uh, I mean, I'm really
glad that you accepted the invitation. So, but before
we get into the actual topic, let me just
ask you, uh, more of a personal question. I
mean, what got you interested in this topic specifically?
What do you think is, uh, I mean, what
stimulates you intellectually about it or intellectually or otherwise,
of course.
Yeah, so, I mean, there's a couple of answers
to that question. So, in undergrad, I majored in
political science and I took a class on um
sex work, sex trafficking, and that entire kind of
topic. It was a quarter long class, and we
looked at different arguments in support of and against,
and we look at statistics and data and all
of that, and I found it really interesting. It's
just fascinating because I hadn't looked at it in
that way before. I really hadn't thought much about
it in general. I also was on the board
of a nonprofit organization, and my position, um, it,
it was a little unrelated to what the actual
nonprofit was supposed to do, but my job was
to bring presentations once a week to the organization
and either me or someone in my A small
subcommittee would give a presentation on a topic. And
I decided one day that I wanted to give
a 45 minute presentation on sex work and whether
we should legalize it, decriminalize it, or keep it
criminalized. And it just generated a great conversation. And
um it, it, it brought something to the surface
that I hadn't really thought of before, like what
criminalization actually does or what legalization. DOES. And we
looked at like Nevada because some counties in Nevada
have um legalized it, and we looked at the
Nordic model, which is more decrim model um up
in Northern Europe. And it was just a great
conversation. Then I went to law school and I
took a class on sex trafficking in law school.
And we had two women who were survivors of
sex trafficking. And of course, sex trafficking is Not
the same as sex work, but there is a
lot of crossover and a lot of people talk
about it. It is in the same realm. And
so we had two survivors who also had opinions
on expanding and legalizing sex work and their thoughts
of that from their own personal perspective, which I
thought was really fascinating. And so, just after all
of these conversations I've had and being in classes,
I really wanted to cover it. Also, I talk
about ethics a lot on my page. I talk
about laws a lot and philosophy like you mentioned
when you introduced me, and so I've talked about
surrogacy. I've talked a lot about bodily autonomy, um,
from the position of abortion. I've talked about, uh,
bottle or just the concept of consent. And so
what I find fascinating about the entire sex work
debate is that it touches a lot of different
topics that we wouldn't think were relevant until we
dove in, like bodily consent, right? Bodily consent is
something that applies to abortion, it applies to sex
work, it applies to decriminalizing drugs. Applies to um
assisted death, all that kind of stuff. OK, so
like, maybe we should talk about it if it,
if it touches all those points. Um, AND similarly,
you know, you have the idea that they're feminists,
right? But they disagree on what we should do
about sex work. That's fascinating. They come from very
different philosophical backgrounds on what we should do with
sex work in whatever country or in the world.
And so I just, I kind of wanted to
Introduce my audience to that and expand on it
and help people realize that these conversations are things
that can be applicable to other things, and that's
why we should be having them.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, no, no, that's really fascinating. I
mean, my own personal experience is just that I'm
a very open-minded person when it comes to exploring
topics that are taboo in society, generally speaking, and
Uh, I mean, I've been fascinating, fascinated by this
topic since I read, uh, intellectual on an intellectual
level, since I read Gerald Mosley, who's a former
attorney from California, sex workers and their clients, which
was released back in 2021, if I remember correctly,
I interviewed him in 2024, and then since then
I just, uh, back, uh, late last year, I
decided to start a series on. My show called
Humanizing Sex Workers, and I've been having conversations on
the show mainly with female escorts and porn stars,
and I mean just personally and maybe uh you
could say that because of that I'm a little
bit biased when it comes to the topic, but
that's perfectly fine with me. Uh I also have
6 or 7 sex worker friends. I mean, 2
of them are porn stars and the other 4
or 5 are escorts, and I, I mean they
have different sorts of experiences. One or 2 perhaps
have a more negative experience. Uh, THE others, um,
and then the other 3 or 4 have positive
experiences, particularly the porn stars, and then the others
are sort of neutral in a way, so it's
More of a, yeah, OK, uh, I, I mean,
I do this, it's mostly for the money. I
mean, I could do other things, but the men,
the money wouldn't be as good and, uh, also
I wouldn't have uh such freedom when it comes
to my schedule and things like that. So, you
know, but I, uh, just to say that I
also have direct, uh, personal experience because of those,
uh, friendships that I have, so.
Mhm. Yeah, yeah. Well, that's, that's great to have
that kind of that background and that experience. Um,
I do want to say just for your audience
and for the sake of, so they know who
I am, I don't take sides. Um, USUALLY when
I talk about these topics, I try and argue
both sides. That's what my video does. I argue
both sides on three main points on sex work
or the 3 big debates. And so in this
case, I'm not going to be taking a personal
opinion. Uh, THAT being said, I will be counter,
I, I'll probably. Counter things you say similar to
how you will probably counter what I say, and
I'll be, you know, arguing both sides and stuff.
So I just kind of want to say just
because I say something does not mean that that
is my personal opinion.
Yeah, I, I mean, I mean during our conversation
here, which I don't really intend to be a
debate, it's more an exploration of the different facets
of sex work. I mean, uh, I, I might
also use, um, argue. Moments that I don't agree
with. It's just to explore the topic here. So,
uh, but I mean, do you think that it's
important for us to define what sex work is
and to understand what really counts as sex work,
because sometimes, I don't know, maybe people might have
an incorrect understanding of what counts as sex work,
and I know that for example there are Organizations
that stand that position themselves against sex work and
are associated, for example, with Christian values and they
go all the way to claiming even that things
like women in magazines that present women in bikinis
that also counts as sex work, which to me
sounds a bit weird. So I mean there are
some. Dreams there, but what is your opinion on
that?
Yeah, that's a hard one. It is interesting. I
actually brought that up and asked Keza that in
my interview. What exactly is sex work? And, um,
you know, that's the individual from Sweden that I
that I interviewed, and she's against legalizing sex work.
She supports the Nordic model. And it's a hard
definition because, you know, does pornography, is that included?
What about stripping? What about sugar daddies? What about,
you know, having a really wealthy Boyfriend who, you
know, sends you on trips. What about being a
stay at home mom, right? And you made your
decision to marry someone because you wanted to be
with a man who could provide, right? Like, where,
where are we? And as you said, like, um,
bikini models, is that sex work, you know, uh,
and so I think we do need to find
a definition for this, just at least for the
sake of our conversation. Um, I would say, in,
in, in the, in the context of our conversation,
sex work should include, like the actual Physical act
of sexual intimacy with another person. So I wouldn't
include stripping, um, or pornography in sex work. That
being said, I think we should still talk about
stripping and pornography. I just, when I say sex
work, I don't want the audience to think that
I'm talking about pornography or um stripping or something
like that. I will just say, you know, um,
pornography, right? I'll, I'll make that difference there. When
it comes to, you know, sugar babies, um, You
know, rich boyfriends, stuff like that. I also wouldn't
consider that sex work. Again, just because we have
to create some kind of line here. Um, YOU
could arguably say that sugar babies are sex work
sometimes in certain cases, and other times not. I
don't know, that's a fuzzy line. But again, I
just think since we have a word for it,
which is, you know, sugar daddy, sugar baby relationship,
we should just call it what it is, which
is that, you know, if you want to think
that it's sex work, that's your own opinion, but
for the sake of conversation and clarity, we should
probably just say the words that they are, right?
Yeah, but, but when it comes to pornography specifically,
I mean, why is it that you do not
tend to consider it sex work, because the act
of sex is present there, right?
Yeah, I mean, that's a great point. I actually
thought of it as you're saying that. I was
like, well, actually, um, you could counter that. I
mean, I think it's mainly just because calling it
pornography makes more sense than calling it sex work.
It has a, it has a word for it
already, so why not use the word that it's
called so that people can tell the difference. There's
also the viewing aspect of it. The purpose of
pornography is for other people to view it. It's
not actually an individual, like trying to pay for
an individual sexual experience. In addition, pornography, at least
in America, involves the First Amendment. Sex work does
not. So if I were to call pornography sex
work, it would get confusing because the First Amendment
gets pulled in there. You got free speech. And
so I think for the sake of like the
concept of free speech in the First Amendment, at
least in America, it makes more sense to separate
the two.
Right, I mean, it's interesting at a certain point
you mentioned there that people sometimes might argue that,
oh, OK, a sugar, sugar daddy, sugar baby relationship
also counts as sex worker for example, if a
wife stays at home and she's supported financially by
her husband and she doesn't really love him anymore
and just has sex with him because, I mean,
to keep the relationship going, maybe. That would also
count as sex work. I mean, I'm just mentioning
that not because I think I agree that that's
sex work, but just because sometimes and because of
conversations I've had with my sex worker friends, sometimes
just as a matter of joking a little bit,
they bring up the fact that, oh, OK, so
people who are against sex work want to condemn
us for having sex for money, but Then there
are women out there who are married, but they're
basically having sex with their husbands for money. So
you know, yeah, no,
I've heard that. I've heard that argument as well.
That argument was brought up in my undergrad class.
People talked about it very often. So, and, and
again, I, I brought that up with Keza. So
it's, um, it's definitely something people talk about. So
it's worth knowing, or or it's, it's worth discussing
whether we want to consider that sex work or
not and talk about that kind of gray area,
the, the sliding spectrum that we're on here, you
know.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, so I mean, of course
if we were to simplify things here we would
say that the two main approaches to sex work
is on the one hand being against sex work
and on the other hand being in favor of
sex work or even if not really in favor
at least defending sex work or sex workers or.
Claim, claiming that we should allow sex work to
to exist, that it's not unethical, that it's ethical.
So, but uh I mean, I mean in your
explorations there, what would you say or what are
the main approaches or position that the positions that
you, uh, you've come across?
Yeah, well, I guess it depends on what kind
of, like, where, what, how you want to come
at it, right? So you have like the basic
decriminalization, criminalization, legalization, right? So from the legal standpoint,
you have those three positions. You could add Nordic
model in there on decrim because it's like a,
it's like a hybrid
almost. It's, it's partial criminalization, right?
Yeah, it's, it's partial. So you, you have that,
right? And then, OK, if you want to talk
about the feminist. Perspectives. You have the radical feminist
abolitionists, and then you have the kind of liberal
feminist slash sex worker right position, right? And so
the radical feminist abolitionists, they argue that prostitution or
sex work is a form of institutionalized male dominance,
no matter what you do. And the very transaction
of sex work is in and of itself a
harm, no matter how much legal protection you have
in there or labor regulation. And it's because consenting
to sex work is the, is essentially consenting to
a system of male dominance, and it's produced by
male dominance, right? So then on the other side,
the sex worker rights position, the liberal feminists, that
has to do with kind of like, Bodily autonomy,
the government acting in a paternal sense, telling women
that they can or can't do something because it
is or is not good for them. Uh, YOU
know, why is sex work any different from any
other kind of work, right? Like, I mean, OK,
we can't really compare. I mean, you could try
to compare it to just, you know, being an
accountant or something. But most comparisons are like, OK,
well, what about being a coal miner, right? That
is a very, um, pain, like very physically exhausting,
very dangerous job. Why is that OK, but sex
workers is not, or a therapist, or a massage
therapist, right? Um, AND so, and then obviously you
get support from sex workers themselves. So I would
say that those are two camps on the more
feminist side, but then you just have like the
everyday people who don't really label themselves, and it's
just like kind of what you said, for or
against it, right? Some people are for it, some
people are against it. Their reasoning might be related
to religion, bodily taunt, like whatever their reasoning, but
then you have that, those two camps.
Yeah, it's interesting. I mean, there, there's many things
there that we can unpack, but uh just to
say that in terms of feminism, yeah, I'm very
well familiar with the different, uh, the two main
camps within feminism. I mean, we, you tend to
have the radical feminism. WHO position themselves against sex
work and then as you said, the liberal feminists,
even though there are some also Marxist slash socialist
feminists who present themselves position themselves in favor of
sex work as well, and I mean it's interesting
because. I mean, there are some arguments there, maybe
we can get into some of them later, but
particularly, for example, I was thinking about when the
radical feminists or the sex negative feminists, if you
want to use that term, sometimes people use that
as well, when they claim that, uh, OK, the,
the real issue there is. The way that you're
selling your body to a particular for a particular
person to make use of it, but I mean,
again, the sex positive feminists and sex workers who
have a positive view of sex work, they say,
yeah, OK, fine, but you also sell your body
for labor to your. Boss or whatever if you
work in construction, if you work in agriculture, if
you work different kinds of physical jobs, physical labor,
and I mean we can also argue that people
who do intellectual labor also sell their brain for
labor. So and I mean at the end of
the day it seems like really what Makes a
difference for sex negative feminists. It's not really selling
the body. It's more like the sexual aspect of
it because they don't seem to have the same
reaction when it comes to even, I don't know,
people literally breaking their back working in construction or
agriculture.
Well, yeah, I think, I think it definitely, you
can't really separate it from the sex aspect of
it. And I've thought about this because the thing
is, is, and, and I'm gonna, I, I'm gonna,
you know, pause the argument for the, the radical
feminist abolitionists is, and just those who are against
legalizing sex work or decriminalizing it in general, but
there is an aspect of sex that is very
vulnerable. And intimate. And I think it's, it's argued
that it's different than if you were to break
your back while doing construction or something like that.
And then you layer on top of that, the
power dynamics between men and women, whether that's like,
in reality, which is that men are stronger than
women on average, or it's a cultural thing, it's
created by the culture, it's that that that men
are in a position of power because the culture,
the patriarchy has put It that way. You, once
you start layering those things, it complicates the situation
and differentiates it from, you know, a coal miner
or a construction worker or something like that. I
also think the fact that sex creates life is
another aspect of it that differentiates it. And I've
thought about this because I know a lot, not
a lot, maybe not every one of them, but
um Keza, at least, who I interviewed, she's also
against surrogacy. Um, AND she thinks that's, and I,
I'm not, I'm not speaking for her on this
one because I haven't, um, jumped into her opinion
on surrogacy. I don't ask her about it in
my interview with her or anything like that, but
surrogacy is another situation. I think this is probably
more related to the commodification of the female body,
right? And essentially using it as like an incubator
for a baby that then is taken away from
that woman and given to somebody else. There is
a Uh, a level of intimacy that I guess
we cannot replicate in other systems of labor. Um,
AND so I do see that argument there, and
I think it's an interesting one to explore.
Yeah, but another thing that we have to keep
in mind, and this is something I've learned by
of course talking mostly with sex workers themselves, but
also again reading the Gerald Mosley book. One interesting
aspect here and that many times people who position
themselves against sex work do not consider is that
There's, um, I mean, a lot, there's many, many
times where basically the clients are paying a sex
worker, but they don't a sex worker, but they
don't have sex with them. I mean they're, they're
there just to talk, just to cuddle, just to,
I don't know, open themselves up about their problem,
the problems that they're having and stuff like that,
and sometimes they even end up developing a sort
of almost a friendship and and sometimes actual friendship
with sex workers. So I mean the thing is,
the thing I'm trying to raise here or the
aspect I'm trying to raise here is that what
we think of as being sex work, I mean
someone paying money to another person to have an
intimate moment with them does not necessarily Involves sex
actually.
YEAH, it's kind of interesting because when you, when
you start talking about it like that, it's like,
well, that's like a therapist, right? Like, I mean,
we go to therapist for an hour and we
create like kind of a personal relationship with them
and we talk to them and of course they
have, they have the credentials to actually help us
with our, you know, with whatever is going on
in our mind, our mental health, but it is
very similar, um, or you could add a massage
therapist in there. I mean, that's a very intimate
experience, right? So, um, Yeah, it's, it's really, again,
it comes back to that kind of gradient. I
think the big thing is the sex aspect of
it, right? Like, is there a, it's, I would
say that's probably the big point is the sex,
the moment that sex occurs, not necessarily, but again,
it's like, OK, well, like, What about cuddling? Like,
I mean, I'm sure at least one of them
is getting aroused while they're cuddling, right? So, I
mean, is that like, is that OK? But I
mean, I'm sure that happens when people are getting
massages too from massage therapists. I don't know. So
it's like how are we really gonna sit here
and like, like um um regulate all of these
things, right? And but that, but that, but that
is the issue with just a Regulation and laws
in general is that I think, and this is
applicable across the board to a lot of different
topics is people are trying to find the perfect
solution, right? But at the end of the day,
laws are either going to overinclude or underinclude people,
no matter what, or situations, right? So what we
should be aiming for is the best version given
the information we have at hand, right? That's a
whole separate conversation because then what's the best and
what's the negative consequence and what's an externality that
we're, how are we going to weigh all these
things, right? But yeah, I mean, when we get
into the nitty gritty, no law or lack of
law is going to cover every single situation. So
what we should be focusing on is how we
are going to weigh the pros and the cons
and which avenue we want to take after that.
But that's where everyone disagrees, right?
Yeah, yeah, that's the thing, yeah, and you're, you're
a lawyer, right, so you have more knowledge about
this than I am, but I mean, it seems
to me that people many times are sort of
aiming at perfect law, perfectly written, that includes all
single except possible exception out there and all of
that, but that simply isn't our. We write or
create or vote laws, right? I mean, it's basically
many times it's a matter of just putting out
there to start with an imperfect law and then
over time evaluating how it actually works in the
real world and the kinds of positive and negative
consequences that it ends up having and then tweaking
it over time. Of course, the way we evaluate
the negative or the positive consequences boils down to
also people's own personal values, right? I mean, because
I mean one person can consider a particular kind
of consequence, a negative consequence. Another person can consider
it neutral or a positive consequence. So at the
end of the day we're also debating morals here.
Mhm. Yeah, exactly. It is, it's a, it's a,
that's why I like talking about, that's why I
talked about it. It's very complicated once you really
get into it, and it's worth having these conversations
because, like I said, it does apply to other
things, like if you want to talk about surrogacy,
like, should surrogacy be legal or not? Why or
why not? Should we regulate these things, right? Like,
at what point is the bodily autonomy argument, and
it, and I think surrogacy is actually, and I
don't want to like, go off on a tangent,
but surrogacy is a really Interesting one because it
involves another human, which is the baby that comes
out, right? So that like, these topics are worth
having conversations on. And I write, I wrote an
article about this on my sub stack, actually, I
was, it's not specific to surrogacy or sex work
or anything like that. But I essentially talk about
like, people have to be very careful when, um,
you know, proposing laws, because a lot of people,
it's very similar to what we said, the overinclusivity,
underinclusivity, how it's going to apply in the future.
A lot of people, when they support a law,
they support it because the politician they like wants
that law to pass. But then I'm like, well,
what if the politician you dislike employed that law?
Would you still support that law? Right? That's why
it's like, OK, once laws are on the, and
it's much easier to get a law in than
get rid of it. Like, everyone's always talking about
all politicians campaign on passing laws. They don't campaign
on necessarily getting rid of laws. I mean, some
do, but not many. It's not nearly as popular,
right? And so, It's like, let's just do more
laws and more laws and more laws. And it's
like, OK, at some point, like, we have overregulation
at this point, and maybe we should have a
conversation about whether we have too many laws on
the books. And also, again, if the politician you
hate employs the law that you support, how does
that, how is that used against you, right, in
your group of people or whoever you're supporting? I
think these are conversations that need to be had.
So yeah, I wrote an article about that because
I think it's like something that that people seem
to forget about.
Yeah, by the way, particularly feminists and sociologists as
well, and of course some sociologists are also feminists
themselves, talk about emotional and sexual labor, labor, not
only, I mean physical labor or intellectual labor or
just. Uh, THEY just, or, or like people usually
do, they just use the term labor without distinguishing
between different kinds of labor. I mean, do you
think that it makes sense in this particular case
to also, uh, talk about emotional and sexual labor?
I mean, sex, the sexual bit is more or
less obvious, right? But The emotional labor aspect to
it has to do with, I mean, things that
I've mentioned before, like the the therapeutic aspect of
it that it can have the companionship aspect of
it. I mean, do you think that it makes
sense to talk about these different kinds of labor
within sex work?
I mean, I would say anything's worth a conversation,
right? Um, SO if people think that emotional labor
should be part of the conversation, it's worth talking
about. I haven't done a ton of research on
the emotional labor argument of sex work, to be
completely honest. Um, WHEN I think of emotional labor,
I think of like every many, many jobs, like,
OK, you're a neurosurgeon. That's a lot of. Emotional
Labor, actually, you know, like, you're a nurse, that's
a lot of emotional labor. You work in an
elderly folks' home. You are a psychologist. There is
always emotional labor involved in every job. So, to
me, I'm just like, yeah, we can have a
conversation. And again, I would like to talk to
sex workers about that one specifically, because emotional labor,
I think is something that is like, That is
a very personal perspective that I would really like
to hear about, cause I can't really guess what
people emotionally feel when they're involved in sex work.
Like that's almost a level above that, right? Like
there aren't really statistics about it. I can look
at data and statistics about like sex work and,
you know, um, sex trafficking and all of that
kind of stuff. I don't have any data about
like the emotional labor involved in sex work, so.
Yeah, no, I mean, I don't have data either.
It's just my, the conversations I've had with sex
workers and some other, I don't know, testimonials that
I read and heard, but I mean there are
different kinds of experience, and I mean I guess
that that's an important point also to put out
there in this conversation that wherever kind of topics
we explore here today in regards to sex work,
there's always people out there. Sex workers who have
negative experiences and others that have positive experiences, others
that others that are more or less in the
middle, more or less neutral, but I mean, I've
heard many different kinds of things when it comes
to emotional labor in sex work. I mean, for
example, sex workers who I know personally that don't
really like sex work is more of a, OK,
so I don't have really good alternatives and I
need to make it to earn this money. I
mean, it were in the living that sometimes they
don't really like having sex with strangers, so to
speak, and then during the act they sort of
dissociate mentally, you know, they're, they're like, they try
to not be there during the act, which sometimes
might come out as, uh, I mean sometimes the
clients might notice that, oh, OK, she's, she's not
engaged or something like that and they. Like that,
but I mean there are others, and I, I,
and this bit here, it gets into also a
little bit of the psychology of it because there
are sex workers out there, uh, escorts and porn
stars, which are the ones I'm more familiar with
than the ones I actually have personal contact with,
where, for example, if they score high on sociosexuality,
sociosexuality is a Psychological trait where people basically are
interested in having sex with a a big number
of people with no strings attached. I mean they
don't really get very emotionally attached with the people
they have sex with and they like sexual variety
and things like that. And, and also, I mean
in the particular case of porn stars, some of
them. EXHIBITIONISTS, so they also feel pleasure just thinking
about other people watching them having sex. So, I
mean the the emotional labor aspect, I guess that
it's always there, but for some, for some people
it's like positive emotional labor if you will, and
for others it's really like um. Negative emotional labor
and it really feels like labor, you know.
Yeah, so, OK, I, I think I might have
misunderstood emotional labor a little bit. Um, SO thanks
for expanding on that. That was helpful. Again, I
haven't, again, I have not done a ton of
research on the emotional labor side of it, but,
you know, when you bring in psychology, the psychological
impact of sex work on the individual sex workers,
that is very interesting, and I think I definitely
think that's worth a conversation. Um, AND it's probably
something that not a lot of people do talk
about. It's hard again, because you don't have the
data, you don't have the statistics per se, but
you do have some biological aspects to it. Like
you said, you have some individuals who, if, uh,
you know, they have the proclivity of having sex
with a lot of different sexual partners, but then
they don't necessarily connect with people on an individual
level. I think that's really interesting. Is that something
that someone is born with? Is that something that
is that nurture in nature, right? Is it something
that can increase, um, when they are involved in
sex work or pornography? So is that a negative
externality depending on how they view it, right? If
they don't care, then it's not negative. But is
it a negative externality? Would we see it as
negative? Um, AND then does that affect this, the,
the society more broadly as a result? Um, SO
those are definitely things to consider.
No, sure, sure, I mean, the, the, the things
I know, of course it's mostly anecdotal from the
conversations I've had with sex workers, but some of
them say that from a very early age, from
the very moment they were exposed to sex in
some form or another, even not necessarily pornography, because
some of them, I mean, Conversations I've had on
the show are have been with people that were
born even in the 50s, 60s, 70s, so even
before porn, you could get porn on VHS or
DVD and even less so on the internet because
there was no internet at all. So when they
were first exposed to sex, it was not through
pornography or anything like that. They say that they
were. From very early on, very interested and very
curious about sex, and then they started exploring it
themselves, and then they found out that they just
liked, I don't know, things like exploring other people's
bodies and things like that, and they are extremely
open to the sex. They don't moralize it at
all, and then I mean, there's that, and then
there's people who told me that basically they didn't
really know that they could, could enjoy sex that
much. It was only after they were in the
porn industry that they opened themselves up a little
bit more to sex, and they found out that
really they, they were missing on something. And I
mean, I'm not sure. Or if that means that
they became over time more sociosexual or if they
were already sociosexual and it's only when they went
through those experiences that they found out that they
actually were sociosexual because sometimes these things are also
repressed in society, right? So, I mean, but there's
different kinds of experiences out there.
Mhm. Yeah. And see, the thing, I think that
should be a big part of this conversation, since
we're talking about like, is it worth talking about
this or that is definitely individual experience is important.
But I also think a large aspect of it
is looking at things, zooming out a little bit
and looking at whether there is a negative or
positive or neutral societal impact of legalizing the Criminalizing
or criminalizing it, right? Like, how does this affect
people more generally? I think that's another, a big
part of the conversation because I, I, it's when,
when you talk to individuals, like I said, very
important. I've heard stories on either side, right? Like
I had to, we had two individuals who came
again, they were, they were introduced to sex trafficking
at a young age, but while there. While they
were there, they interacted with individuals who were involved
in sex work on the more like decriminalized, legalized
side, and they are very involved in sex trafficking
now and that they're combating it. And so they
work with people in that realm. And so in
their opinion, they were actually very against it, uh,
which was a very interesting, and they actually have
very interesting opinions. Um. And it's worth taking that
into consideration. But then, yeah, like, let's, another step
is, OK, so how does this affect the general,
in, in general, how does it affect society? Um,
SO, I think it's another conversation we had.
No, OK, it's OK, so let's get into that
topic then. I mean, the different ways that people
claim it can affect society have to do with,
of course, how it can affect the sex workers
themselves and more broadly how it can affect the
consumers. I mean, if we're, if we're including porn
and things like Only Fans here, I mean the,
the way that it can. Affect societies is much
broader because it's not like, OK, so if you
pay for sex and you have direct intimate access
to a woman, for example, I mean it's only
one person at least at the time that is
affected by sex work, but if we're talking about
pornography that you can find on the internet, it
can potentially affect millions or billions of people. VERY
rapidly, right? So I mean there's also the impact
on people talk about the impact on men particularly
because I, I know that the statistics have been
changing a little bit over the past 10 years
or so. The number of women who have watched
pornography has increased 50%. So, uh, I mean the,
the gender gap there is decreasing, but still it's
a major. It's still a majority of men that
consume pornography, and then people also talk about things
like how it can affect relationships, romantic relationships, particularly.
Sometimes they also talk about how it can affect
children. So I mean, what are the, among all
of those ways that people claim it can affect
society, which are the ones that you think are
the most worth exploring?
Uh, WELL, I think a big one is how
it affects sex trafficking. That, that, um, connection or
alleged connection is, I think, incredibly important because when
you dive into the statistics, you can find support
on either side, right? And that's where it gets
really frustrating on my end because I really want
to find an answer to these questions. And then
I'm looking into it and it's like, yeah, you
find um in you, you find statistics and data
and research that says that when you decriminalize sex
work, Or when you legalize it, you do get
an increase in sex trafficking. And one of the
theories as to why that happens is because the
demand is always going to be greater than the
supply, because it is harder to find women who
want to be involved in sex work, than it
is to find men who want to have sex
with women and pay for it, right? And so
what happens is when this market happens, and that
supply or the demand increases, the supply has to
meet that demand, and the supply happens with sex
trafficking. Um, OR some kind of coercion, right, involved.
And that I, I always found that to be
a very interesting, um, you know, theory and something
to really consider. Then on the other side though,
you do have statistics that say that it makes
it and, and theories that say that it makes
it easier to determine who's being sex trafficked and
not being sex trafficked when you legalize it, because
you have that difference. Right. And individuals who are,
who are consensually participating in sex work, they feel
comfortable going to police and saying, hey, this man
tried to assault me. And, and they're protected by
the police. When it's, when it's illegal, they're not
protected by the police. They are a criminal as
well. So not only are they a victim, they're
also a criminal. And that puts them in a
very hard position, which is
I was actually I was actually going to say,
sorry for interrupting you, but I was actually going
to say, do you think that there's a possibility
that at least a percentage of those cases where,
as you said, when where sex work is legalized
or decriminalized, we see sex trafficking going up, do
you think that at least The percentage of those
cases of sex trafficking could be simply that where
it's legalized or decriminalized, people feel, feel more at
ease going to the police or to other kinds
of authorities and really denounce what's happening in, uh,
I mean, vis a vis, for example. PLACES where
it's criminalized and they don't feel at ease doing
that and so what could happen is that in
places where it's decriminalized or legalized, you would see
sex trafficking cases of sex trafficking going up because
police are more aware of that. But in places
where it's criminalized, people just don't go to the
police because they don't want to get into trouble
themselves. I mean, do you think that's a possibility?
For, for sure. I think it's possible that they're
growing up at the same time, right? And that's
why this is so hard to do is because
there's so many variables. It's like, how are you
actually supposed to figure this out? Definitely think that
it's a possibility it's actually probably happening, that the
number of recorded sex trafficking victims goes up because
it can be recorded because people have the, the
freedom to safely approach police officers or go to,
um, you know, organizations that are There to help
them and not be criminalized and thrown in jail
or fined, right? For sure. But I also do
think that it could go up because of like
the theory I mentioned, the supply and demand aspect
of it, and it might make it easier since
it's legal to kind of skirt the line as
to what exactly sex trafficking is and isn't, um,
instead of it just being completely illegal across the
board, right? It makes it a little easier for
them. So I think, I think it could, what
it probably is, is a combination of both, um,
and trying to figure out which it is, or
which is more or less. That's a hard one
to do. That's really hard to do, and I
think we need those answers.
But I think there's also a discussion to be
had here, and we can have it if you
want as to how people define sex trafficking, because
I think, I think that one position that we,
you can hear very frequently out there in these
kinds of debates comes from people who are Against
sex work and they make claims like, oh, OK,
so all sex work is sex trafficking because no
woman out there, of course we also have to
keep in mind that there are male sex workers,
but we're focusing on the women here because they
represent the bulk of sex workers. So but No
woman out there would willingly, freely, autonomously decide to
become a sex worker. They are necessarily coerced into
it, and so if they are coerced, it is
nonconsensual. If it's nonconsensual, then it's always sex trafficking.
But I think that's actually very, I mean, Even
putting the morality aspect of it aside, if just
from a pure intellectual perspective, it seems very intellectually
dishonest because we're just assuming then that an entire
economic activity is illegal, it is done nonconsensually because
I mean, in this case, I guess people don't
like it and equating it to sex trafficking and
Sex work is not always sex trafficking.
Mhm, FOR sure. And you know, I think that
is a common argument used when it's used for
argument's sake. And I'll, I'll try to explain that,
like, so for example, I was looking into something
that really surprised me when, when I was, I
was much younger, I was like in my early
twenties, and it's when I give my presentation on
sex work to my nonprofit organization. And I found
um a good number of negative reviews about the
legalization of sex work in counties in Nevada, which
I didn't, I just didn't expect that that was
going to be the case. So I did some
more research on it more recently, actually in preparation
for this, and I just wanted to like read
a little bit more, and I came across a
website that was is against the legalization of sex
work in counties in Nevada, and it talks about
how, you know, there is a lot of intersection
of legal sex work and sex trafficking because a
lot of women in the legal brothels who are
sex workers legally. HAVE reported feeling coerced. And so
that's essentially exactly what you're saying here is that
there is a coercion element to it. And trying
to figure out whether that's considered sex work or
sex trafficking is really hard, especially because coercion exists
outside of sex work as well. Like, I mean,
we're kind of all coerced to work, right? We're
trying to stay alive. So it's, I mean, like,
we're doing it for money. Um, SO that's, so.
That argument is definitely made. But when you look
at statistics, the question is, how are they recording
it, right? Are they recording sex trafficking based on
the, the criminal aspect of it, the legal definition?
Is it that they are truly police officers or
Detectives or whoever is in charge of this, the
government looking into this, because in that case, it's
like, well, it's not really argument's sake, right? They're
not just like, hopefully, they're not just saying, oh,
this is all sex trafficking because no sex work
can ever be consensual because of this theory. When
we look at it like that, I would like
to believe that the statistics are a little more
um trustworthy because they're based on a more a
legal definition, not necessarily a theory. That being said,
I don't know if that's necessarily the case, which
is why when you look at these studies, you
have to figure out the actual methodology of how
they're determining whether something is sex trafficking or sex
work, right? So.
Yeah, but I think that's one of the reasons
why in these kind of conversations it's almost impossible
to avoid the psychological aspect of things, because if
you want to argue that all women who participate
in sex work are being sexually trafficked then or
are victims of. Sex trafficking, you're making also a
claim about their internal psychological state, right, because you're
assuming that they don't want to be there. They
were forced into being there and you're also claiming,
even though indirectly, that every sex worker out there.
Who says explicitly that no, they're doing that voluntarily,
they're doing that out of their own free will.
They are, they made their own choice. They're, they're
calling them liars basically because
or just being paternalistic. They're saying they're essentially saying
like you don't know, like you don't actually know,
you're being. But I mean, those arguments are made
everywhere for a lot of different things is essentially
like you're just, you know, internalized misogyny or stuff
like that, which is just like, you might think
you know what you know, but you don't actually
know. I know what you know, and I'm, you
know, that's a very common one, but I agree,
like that's why the psychology does need to be
discussed. But the the psychology needs to be discussed
because I think That if we actually want a
system where women are able to make educated decisions
as to what they want to do with their
bodies or not, they need to be educated on
the potential psychological ramifications of what they're doing or
not doing. And I think at this point, because
both sides are trying to argue that the other
side is right or wrong, and they're so focused
on that, that they're essentially imputing a belief. System
on, on each other, right? You have a lot
of sex workers that come out in support of
sex work saying, I want to do it. Therefore,
whatever you're saying is wrong. And, you know, this
exists, right? And then you have the other side
that's like, well, there's no way that you actually
want to believe it because, or you actually want
sex work because you're operating within a patriarchal society
that has made you believe that. That is what
you want, but you don't actually want it. And
so it's like, OK, so now you're just telling
each other what the other person wants or doesn't
want, and there is a little asymmetry there, and
I don't want to lose that. I think that
the people who are arguing against sex work are
a little more trying to impute a belief system
on the other, but that again is why I'm
like, well, the bigger picture should be like, we
need to actually look at the psychological impact. And
then not impute the potential feelings that somebody has,
but rather educate the possibility of this so that
individuals can make their own choices. And then another
step would be to look at the larger, broader
implications of all of this, rather than like whether
a single individual does or does not like something
at any given time. And that's why I like
if we want to go back to pornography, so
when I was looking at this Nevada website or
this website about Nevada legalization, It did bring up
a very interesting point that I think is worth
having a conversation about, because it essentially talks about
how with the increase in normalization of pornography and
the increase of consumption of pornography, we have had
an increase of interest in violent pornographic material, and
that sex workers have reported experiencing an increase in
violence against them because as individuals watch this porn
and they get more desensitized, they then want to
replicate those actions against the sex workers. That's, that's
a negative externality. That I think it is worth
having a conversation about. And it's something that we
should be able to talk about without necessarily thinking
that we're any, we're conceding any given point, because
this is something that I've noticed in any debate,
is that no, no one wants to admit that
there might be a flaw in their belief, because
to concede anything is almost like to give the
other side the, the advantage in a debate, right?
And so you're just like, no, this is not
the case. And it's like, OK, well, in an
actual Conversation where we're trying to figure out how
to better society and better individual lives and figure
out if we want to legalize it or not,
we have to talk about the negatives and positives
of both sides so that we can properly weigh
what we want to do. But that's very dangerous
when things become political and everyone's just, no one's
willing to actually concede any point that the other
side might be correct, right?
Mhm. No, I mean, just two quick points, and
then let's talk a little bit more about because
you've already Mentioned there as well ways by which
pornography or sex work more generally can affect society,
but I mean the two points I wanted to
make is when it comes to the asymmetry you
mentioned there, when it comes to one side or
the other trying to impose their values on the
opposite side, I think that the asymmetry goes a
little bit further than what you said in the
sense that, OK, so people who are against sex
work. Generally speaking, are all trying to eliminate sex
work, to abolish sex work, ban sex work. I
mean, to get rid of sex work, ideally to
completely get rid of it, but sex workers are
people who defend sex work. I mean, I don't
think I've ever had a conversation with anyone who
said that. Sex work, for example, is OK for
everyone that anyone should go into sex work. They
admit or recognize that there are some, or some
of its aspects can have a negative impact on
people. They refer to different things like, for example,
if you don't have the right kind of personality
to really Feel well with having sex with uh
different people and mainly strangers, and they also mention,
for example, uh, OK, so in the long term,
you have to keep in mind that, for example,
if you are a porn star, that your image
will be there on the internet for the rest
of your life and the kind of negative consequences
that that might have. And, OK, so they tend
to recognize some of what might potentially be negative
about sex work, and they all of them, or
at least all the ones that I've heard, say
that no, sex work is not for everyone and
also in terms of the consumers, they have to
have a healthy relationship to sex work, that for
example, They shouldn't treat pornography as real sex because
it's not real sex. They also admit that. And
the other thing, the other point I was going
to make is, yeah, I, I completely grant you
the fact that people on either side are looking
at things from their specific vantage points because of
course, even though I'm friends with sex. Workers, I'm
willing to admit that probably some of them, if
not all of them, also tend to develop these
positions favorable towards sex work because they're, um, it's
their living. I mean, it's the way they're making
their living, it's how they earn the money, so
I mean it's just natural that they would attend
toward that and. On the other end of the
spectrum, I mean, people who are against sex work
are the ones who tend to have particular kinds
of beliefs surrounding sex, gender roles. They tend to
moralize different aspects of sex and all of that.
So I, I mean those are just two points
I wanted to make. But then when it comes
to the negative impacts, I mean for me some
of the claims made by People who say that
sex work has or can have a negative impact
on society, at least some of those claims are
a bit shaky scientifically speaking, because for example, when
they claim that sex work can cause sexual violence
or sex crimes. I mean, it's, it's real, that
the foundation for that is extremely shaky. I've, I've
had conversations on the show with psychologists, sociologists, neuroscientists
who study those kinds of topics, and And for
the longest time we've, we've seen that actually has
the consumption of pornography, for example, has gone up,
sex-related crimes have been going down, at least from
places where we have proper. Data. So I mean,
uh, when you say that we need to look
at the possible or potential negative impacts that sex
work can have on society, is that, are you
referring to that type of thing, or, or do
you have other specific examples?
Well, that's one example, but another, like we talked
about would be whether sex trafficking goes up when
legal or when legalization or decriminalizing comes up. Um,
ANOTHER one would be just the general commodification of
the female body or the, the impact of like
seeing sex as a commodity, how that might affect
the general population. But I do want to point
out is, um, you know, I have not talked
individually to sociologists or neuroscientists or psychologists on this
specific thing when it comes to pornography or anything
like that. Um, THAT being said, I do want
to point out that there could be a confounding
variable in that case, which is that as pornography,
um, has increased more, maybe, um, understanding and policing
and all of that has also increased in general.
Education of consent has increased. And that might be
another variable as to why we see, you know,
these sex acts decreasing. It's not necessarily that porn
increasing is affecting that, but more that there is
simultaneously something else going on that is helping kind
of combat the, the effect that porn might be
having, having on individuals. Also, but, but that's, that's,
that comes back to the issue, which is that
like, you have This is the issue with like
everything, which is why it's so frustrating, like everything,
which is you have so many variables, and you
have so many different things to look at. It
is really hard to find causation on any of
this kind of stuff, because it's like, well, you
know, again, we have women who have reported, um,
you know, an increase in abusive tendency towards them,
and they associate that with the increase of pornography.
OK, but I'm sure there are other variables as
to why that might be the case. You know,
you know what I mean, like how are we
actually supposed to track all of this stuff? That's
a really hard thing to do. And, um, so
yeah, I, I also, another thing I found interesting,
and you just made me think of it while
you're talking about it. Have you looked into how
the UK has, um, haven't they made it illegal
to have a strangulation or any kind of choking
in pornography because of its impact on women? Did
that, was that, did that happen?
Yeah, I haven't followed that closely. I heard about
that. Very, in a very vague way, but yeah,
possibly that possibly has happened, but I'm not sure.
I can't really.
I think it would be really interesting to dive
into that and see what studies they use to
support that law, if they use studies to support
that law, and what caused them to do that.
I think that's a really interesting legal move that
the UK recently did. If it, I'm pretty sure
they did do that. And please, anyone in the
audience, correct me. If it was like maybe a
proposed and it didn't like pass, but pretty sure
it passed, um, or something similar to it, because,
again, this is why these conversations are so important,
because the laws are getting passed, or at least
being proposed that affect this kind of stuff. And
like, as we continue to move on and tech
gets better and policing gets better, but also, we
are pushing for more liberalization or less liberalization of
certain actions, when you have these conversations.
No, of course, and I mean, to be perfectly
honest, there are, OK, so when it comes to
how porn might affect porn or sex work more
generally might affect society, of course, the sex, violence,
sexual violence kind of stuff is just one type
of claim that people who are against sex work
make. There are many different types of claims. And
of course I don't think we have time to
explore all of them here, but, uh, but, but
anyway, there are at least some aspects of people's
lives that even in those conversations, so for example,
a conversation I had with Dr. Nicole Rosi, she's
a neuroscientist who really focuses on sex, pornography, and
the effects that pornography has or doesn't have. ON
people and one of the things that we talked
about in one of our conversations we've had too
on the show is where porn can actually have
a negative effect on people is, for example, let's
say that we're talking about a couple, a heterosexual
couple, a man and a woman, and the man
really watches a lot of pornography and the woman.
DOESN'T really or watches very little, so the thing
is that the discrepancy there might have a negative
impact on the relationship because I mean the woman
might start thinking, oh, why is it that he's
watching so much porn. Porn. Why does he need
to watch porn so regularly or all the time?
I mean, am I not enough? And then she
might start comparing herself to the porn performers and
think that, OK, she's maybe she's not sexy enough
or beautiful enough or perhaps she's not as Uh,
or good and bad as they are, stuff like
that. So yeah, pornography can for sure in certain
circumstances have a negative impact on people, and that's
one example.
Well, and I have a question, is the neurologist.
Did you say woman, man? What's her name?
Her name is a, she's a woman. Nicole, Nicole
Prosi.
Did she study why a man would want to
watch pornography while he's in a committed relationship to
a woman who he could have sex with?
Yeah, there, there are at least a bunch of
reasons. I mean, I'm not sure if I will
be able to remember all of them, but one
reason would be that, OK, so people have this
idea that, for example, people who watch a lot
of porn are just, I don't know, hopeless people
who can't really have access to sexual partners and
things like that, but actually, It tends to be
the case that people who watch more porn, and
this is true for both men and women, are
people who have a higher sex drive. They are
more interested in sex, and so they watch more
porn, but they also tend to have more sex
sometimes with even more than one person. And so
what happens when they are in a relationship is
that they still watch porn, not because they don't
like their partner, their partner is not good enough,
or their partner does not satisfy their needs. It's
just that. I mean that the uh that they
still, even though they have lots of sex, they,
because their sex drive is so high, they still
feel the need to watch porn, and many times
it has nothing at all or very little to
do with their partner or them being tired of
their partner or their partner not being good enough
in bed or. Uh, SOMETHING like that, so it's
not necessarily a case of, uh, so some people,
uh, look at it as a case of, uh,
betrayal or cheating or something like that. Oh, you're
watching porn, you're not having sex with me or
you don't have want to have sex with me
anymore, or you're interested in those kinds of women
and not in me, something like that. But no,
that's not necessarily the case,
so. Yeah, I mean, I guess I just, again,
I have not looked into the studies a ton
on this, but I, I would be very curious
to see as to why, like, I'm going to
make the guess that the only reason why people
watch porn is not because they have higher sex
drive than their partner. I'm just saying that's not
the only reason. So I'm just curious as to
what other reasons are impacting them and why some
people would choose to do it, why they would
not, because that would make me believe that there
is a psychological connection. PORN usage or porn watching
and not. And if that is the case, how
else might that that affect them? And that that's
a causality thing that's like a chicken before the
egg kind of thing, like, are they watching, are
they wanting to watch porn because of something else,
or is porn wanting them making want to watch
more? Is there any, what is that cycle there?
And then in turn, whether that's going to affect
the uh. Woman, the woman in that case, not
just because she like, feels offended or she's has
personal issues with it, but whether it actually is
going to affect like the sex later on or
something, because then that would, that would apply to
whether it's affecting sex workers or not. I just
think that that's something that I need to look
into a little bit more, and I'm very curious
about.
No, no, no, that's perfectly fair, and I think
that another example where porn can actually affect people's
sexual lives has to do with And this seems
to me very clear, of course, again. It's very
hard to establish a real causal connection there, a
causal relationship, but, um, I mean, it's just the
case that over the past few years, I'm not
sure if it's been a decade or a decade
and a half or more than that, but, uh,
I remember reading data from the UK and younger
people, uh, have been increasingly, particularly, particularly men have
been asking increasingly. FOR their female partners to have
anal sex and stuff like that, and there's a
um I I I mean, I think it's safe
to say that some of that has been influenced
by pornography and by people watching pornography. I mean
there are certain, I don't know, kinks or sexual
acts where people have been influenced by pornography and
another way that have just come to my mind
when. In regards to how porno or pornography consumption
might
erectile dysfunction is also another way like they have
found connections between increased porn use and erectile dysfunction
that does affect that, I mean. This is, I'm
not a doctor here, but I do think it
has a psychological effect then, or performance anxiety is
another one. That's another aspect of it. I've I've
read studies about that. So, it, it is, it
is. And then, you know, how does that apply
to sex work and how does it apply to
the commodification of the body? This is why I
think, and, and I actually have a question for
you. I think this is a good question. We
sit here and we're talking about like, OK, well,
there's this variable and this variable, and like we
can't really, we can, we can see potential correlation,
we can't really create causation, and what do you
think should determine whether sex work should be legal
or not? Like, what do you think that we
should be looking at? Because it seems like looking
at the studies is kind of hard, right? So
is there, but then you say morality, OK, where
does morality come from? But how are we supposed
to be doing this?
OK, so those are two different sets of questions.
I mean, when, when it comes to what we
should be looking at, I mean, for me personally,
but, but again, it's when we have these kinds
of questions, it's really, really hard to separate one's
own personal values from how we evaluate the impact
of things in society, right, because I mean, But
if someone really showed me convincing evidence that, OK,
so pornography, for example, or sex or sex work
escorting really does deeply affect people's ability to form
stable relationships. It really does have a negative impact
on children's sexual development. Uh, IT has an impact
on, for example, increased rates of sexual dysfunction, erectile
dysfunction, uh, I mean, all of those kinds of
things. If people showed me convincing evidence of that,
OK, I would be. Open to considering perhaps imposing
some limitations on sex work, what those limitations would
be, I mean, I would have to discuss that
with people. I'm, I'm not sure when it comes
to the morality aspect of it, I mean, because
I'm very much into psychology and social science, I
mean, I'm just. Where that people's morals come from
different places. I mean, partly it can be genetics,
partly it can be people's own personal experiences, but
for me, I mean, whether it's genetics, whether it's
personal experiences, whether it's nature or nurture. I mean,
it's, it's really complicated for me to position myself.
If those negative consequences for society are not there,
it's really hard for me to position myself on
the side of people who are against sex work
because it's like, oh, OK, so now what you're
doing is that you don't really like sex work
because of your morality. It can be religious or
not, it doesn't matter because you have a morally
negative view of sex work. You're positioning yourself against
it, and now you want to prohibit or prevent
people from engaging in it. I mean, if there's
really no good evidence of those negative consequences, I
mean, are you really going to curb other people's
freedom just on that basis, and then. Uh, YOU
also have, if you're going on morals, then you
also have to consider the other end of the
spectrum. I mean, uh, there are people who are
perfectly fine with sex work for some of the
reasons I mentioned earlier. They might score high on
sociosexuality, they might just have a high sex drive,
they might be very open to experience, I don't
know, many different kinds of traits like that, and
so, And as, and, and if again, if those
negative consequences are not there and so if they
are not in any significant way harming other people,
I mean, it's just hard for me to to
really take the anti-sex work position very seriously, either
morally or even less so legally.
Mhm, YEAH, I get what you're saying, yeah, I
think. And then this is, we've been talking about
this a lot, we kind of come back to
it is like, I'm, I again, we need to
have a better understanding of the potential negative externalities
or lack thereof, in order to discuss whether sex
work should be legal or not. I, it's just
really hard because, you know, I had another podcaster
who I'm on. Show every quarter. And he um
proposed talking about, like, how the modern, like the
younger generation, like Gen Z, um, millennial, and I
guess below Gen Z now, uh, how they're, they're
struggling. There's a lot of a more negative viewpoint
as to our future. And there's a lot of
um struggles in the dating world and a lack
of commitment and people and all these problems, and
I'm just like, yeah, like, but what are, what's
causing these problems? How are we problems? I mean,
maybe some people don't think they're problems, but a
lot of people experiencing them do find it a
problem because they're trying to find someone and they're
like, the dating sucks. Um, BUT it is, it's
very interesting how all of these things interact with
each other and how they interact and how we
can solve these things in the best way possible.
Like, how do we solve it? I just, it's,
it is, it is hard. And then when you
bring up the morality aspect of it, it's like,
yeah, OK, so what's the baseline morality here? What
morality are we going to base off of? Cause
you said, you said some people morally say it
is OK. Some people morally say it's not OK.
So how are we going to choose which moral
baseline we're going to use? Both are arguing from
a moral stance, right? Um, AND that's subjective, in
that situation. So yeah, I think, um,
I mean when it comes to the morality aspect
of things, I look at society as more of
a sort of dynamic, sort of a dynamical system
where people with different interests that stem many times
from their different kind of sets of moral beliefs
are constantly, I mean, trying to tweak society in
ways that favor their own interests and their own
moral values, and I mean over time things change.
Sometimes they move more in one direction, sometimes they
move more on the other direction. So I mean
that that's how I look at things. I, I
don't. REALLY have a sort of idealized view of
morality where it's like, oh, OK, so this is
definitely the absolute moral truth and that's where society
should move toward. I mean, um. It's like moving.
The goalposts are constantly moving and people react also
to the circum the circumstances they live in. So
that's how I look at a moral, a moral
evolution in society and things like that.
Yeah, I mean, and that's a whole separate conversation,
but it is a fascinating one because it's like,
is morality subjective or is there a benefit to
having an objective morality? I actually, I have a
short video about this on my Instagram, but I
talk about Marquis Dessau. Who, um, he, the word
sadism came from him, and he essentially argued like
morality is subjective. Since morality is subjective, it does
not exist. Therefore, I can do whatever I want.
Um, AND if you look at his history, he
did whatever he wanted. And, um, it's just fascinating
when you, uh, when, when you have a situation
where somebody takes something to the most extreme. Which
is that that's what it was. It was taking
the idea that because morality is subjective and therefore
it does not necessarily exist, and there is no
universal right or wrong, they took it to the,
the extreme next step, and they're like, therefore I
can do essentially what I want and I should
be able to. Fascinating conversation, but
yeah, actually, I, I mean, if you, if you
don't mind, because just uh let me just take
a step back because just a couple of minutes
ago you mentioned one thing that people also try
to Uh, or linked to sex work and sometimes
they also try to link it to feminism that
has to do with dating and mating, right? Because
I, I, I mean if you're open to it,
actually I have a sort of. Working theory which
includes several different factors, and none of them has
anything to do with sex work or feminism that
I think can explain the modern dating and
mating. I'd love to hear it. I'm curious.
Oh, OK, so, OK, so my theory starts with
this. I mean, I'm going to go through the
several different factors, not necessarily in order. It depends
on. The sequence I remember them in. So, I
mean, so, so first of all, I, I think
that it has a lot to do with economic
circumstances. So, and particularly in the West, and because
that um dating thing that we're talking about a
lot nowadays, and most of the data comes from
the West, that's why I'm focusing on it. I
mean, since the 2008 economic crisis, I mean, basically
people's economic prospects, uh, job uh um prospects in
the job uh the, the job market and all
of that have been really dire, particularly for the
younger generations, and again, it's the younger generations mostly
complaining about dating. Uh, AND so the, the, the
reason why economics affects dating is, so if you
don't have a stable income, if you, if your
finances are not stable. I mean, it's really hard
to really date and mate because what are you
going to look forward to? I mean, if you're
constantly worried about, oh my God, what if I
lose my job tomorrow when jobs are increasing. More
precarious and you, you don't have this or that
kind of benefit and maybe your income is not
really that great, particularly now with escalating inflation and
all of that and I mean incomes have not
really been keeping up with inflation. So, and uh
also, the reason why I mentioned that is, or,
uh, there's a very clear example in Japan where
in the early 90s they have uh an economic
crisis there and before the economic crisis, their lifestyle
was like, OK, so I go to a university,
wherever kind of degree I feel. I'm going to
immediately have access to one of the public companies
that they, they have or they used to have
in Japan, and I will have a job for
life with a stable income, so I'm able, I'm
going to be able to marry and to have
kids and to raise a family and pay for
my bills. And I won't have to worry about
ever, uh, I mean, getting fired or losing my
job or not having a stable income. But then
the economic crisis hit and that's when from the
early 90s up till now, marriage rates fell, the
dating market has been a mess. There are fewer
and fewer young people. Having regular sex or dating
and having boyfriends or girlfriends and fertility rate also
started to go down precipitously, so I mean, that's
just one example, but for me the economic aspect
of things really has a huge impact on people's
romantic and sexual lives. And then because of economic
instability, another thing that that creates is that, oh,
OK, so we have, we have, we live in
a society where traditional gender roles. Still are still
very prevalent. And so, I mean, what happens when,
for example, younger men do not go to university
as much or do not have access to high,
uh, to high incomes and I I I don't
know, in career job in, in, in high income
jobs and, and stuff like that. I mean, Basically,
if you're expecting men to be providers and a
one income household, I mean that's just not going
to happen. I mean, in the current economy all
across the West, that's just not realistic at all
unless you are really a rich guy. I mean,
that's just not realistic at all. And, and then
another aspect is Younger generations, and this is something
that people have been really looking at for the
past maybe 3 or 4 years. I think that
the first time I read about that was in
2024, if I'm not mistaken. I mean, younger generations
politically there's been a split. Younger women have been
moving more and more toward the left, and younger
men have been moving more and more toward the
right. I mean, what's behind that, it's very complicated
and it would take a huge while to talk
about that here. So I'm not going to get
into that. Just to say that the fact that
younger women and younger men politically are going in
different directions, that also really complicates things because something
that we You hear a lot nowadays when for
example interviewing young women about their dating experiences is
things like, oh, I went on a date with
a guy, but he was, I don't know, a
Trump supporter or he was into manosphere things and
he was really right wing and he was deep
into his religious values and some and things like
that. So women more progressive, men more conservative. I
mean that doesn't really work at the end of
the day. I mean, I mentioned, uh, if I
remember correctly, 33 different aspects there economics, gender roles,
and politics. I mean, maybe I'm missing something here,
but basically what I'm trying to say here is
that I think you can fully explain issues with
the current dating environment without. REALLY resorting to sex
to explanations based on sex work and or feminism.
Yeah. Uh, SO, two things I want to say.
I, um, I think your point on the economy
is a really good one, and I do agree
with that. I actually, I wrote an article, or
sorry, an article, I wrote a paper in undergrad
about how the one-child policy affected China, um, both
demographically, but economically as well. And so, a lot
of people, you know, they only had one kid
because the law said you can only have one
kid. But then China. REALIZED that that was a
terrible idea, because they had a ton of very
old people and a very small um taxing base,
right? And the older people needed, you know, the
healthcare pensions, all of that, but China couldn't tax
that many people to make that money. So then
they got rid of the one child policy because
they're like, we need more kids, we need more
people to tax essentially. But the thing is, is
they found that they, it did not really help.
The demographic crisis, because the middle, the middle age
or middle aged, the 20 year olds, I guess,
the generation that they're trying to get to have
more kids was like, hey, we're strapped for cash.
Um, THERE'S only one of us, and we have
to take care of our parents, because you guys
can't take care of our parents. And also, it's
very, it's very strong in Chinese culture to take
care of your parents. So like, we're financially strapped,
we're taking care of our Parents, there's not a
lot of us, and we're not going to have
kids because we can't afford to have kids. And
so even though the one child policy was no
longer enacted, people were not having kids or only
having one kid. And so it was an economic
reason as to why people were choosing not to.
Of course, there's also a gender aspect, which is
the fact that there are way more men than
women, um, which only compounded the problem. But it's
a very fascinating kind of case study. Um, AND
then I also want to say, In regards to,
I think there are, I think your three points
are good points. I think there are some additional
ones. Uh, I, I do think that this is
a, this is a working theory on my end,
but I do wonder if part of it, and
this is somewhat in relation to the gender political
realm, if young women and girls were, when they
actually this could be related to feminism, but as
we progressed as a society, Women were young girls
were pushed to go to university and stuff or
expected to go to university, and I'm not saying
that in a negative way at all. Obviously, I
went to university and I went to law school,
and I am a lawyer. So like, I, what
happened is a lot of girls started going to
school and stuff, and we're not focused on, you
know, the kind of more stereotypical view of male
female gender roles. So you said it is gender
roles, but I'm actually gonna maybe push back on
it a little bit in that it was almost
like The, the loss of gender roles, because what
happened is at the same time that was happening,
not many people, it seems, were pushing young men
to learn how to do household duties. So what
happens is a lot to me, it seems a
lot of girls know how to do a lot
of different things. They can work a job, make
money, and they can do the dishes, and they
can cook, and they can do the household stuff.
But at that same time, there was no one
teaching little boys how to do the household stuff.
So now we have an asymmetry where a lot
of women are like, Hey, like, I need somebody
that can do everything because I can do everything
and to actually work in a partnership where we're
in an economy where we have to have two
people working. We also have to have two people
doing household chores. So I think that there's a
little asymmetry there. Um, THAT, that's just how what
I've noticed when I was, I'm engaged now and
have been with him for 2.5 years. Um, AND
he knows how to do all the household chores
and also work, which is awesome. Um, THANK you
to his mom. Uh, SHE'S great. But, um, I,
I had been on dates with men who like
couldn't do literally anything, and I was like, well,
I can, like, I'm a lawyer, dude, like I
could do all these things. And so I think
that there might have been some kind of asymmetrical
education there where girls were pushed to be educated
and get jobs, and men were not taught the
more the other side of the picture, and then
the economy comes in, and so everyone's kind of
struggling to date in that situation. I think that's
just kind of a theory of mine. Um, YOU
can disagree or people. In the comments can disagree
or add their opinion on that because it's a
working theory, but
no, no, yeah, sure, no, I definitely agree that
that must have an impact on relationship satisfaction. Actually,
the fourth factor I wanted to mention that I
missed just a few minutes ago, it just came
to mind. I mean, the other factor I think
that really has had an impact on dating has
to do with how we organize society. Over time,
so more and more and more people nowadays are
living in cities, and the way we organize cities,
particularly around cars and all of that, increasingly there's
fewer and fewer what sociologists call third spaces where
people can go, I don't know, parks and cafes
and things like that. I mean, Cafes are more
complicated because actually you have to, um, I mean
you have to spend some money there. When sociologists
refer to food spaces, it's mostly public spaces where
people can meet and interact and meet new people
and all of that, and we have few, increasingly
fewer and fewer of those in our modern cities,
particularly in the West. And so, Uh, it's hard
for people to meet new people, uh, and also
since people live, uh, outside of their original communities.
I mean, many people are born in, I don't
know, villages or small towns, and then eventually they
have to move to cities to find a proper
work there. And so, They are separate from their
family and their communities. I mean, because traditionally people,
their partners and their sometimes lifelong partners, they've they
used to meet them locally. I mean they sometimes
even their family arrange them to meet potential partners,
sometimes. It was people from their broader community, but
it was, it's easier for people to date when
they have a social network that can connect them
to other people that they can potentially date when
they're living in a small apartment in the middle
of New York where they barely know anyone. And
they're trying to meet new people just by themselves.
I mean, that's extremely hard. That's really hard. And
so what people do when they don't have those
choices available when they don't have a broader social
network that can connect them to new potential partners
is that they turn to dating apps and I
mean, and look, I know that. There are many
success stories out there of people meeting their partners,
their husbands and wives on dating apps. I know
that that happens, but for the most part, dating
apps are really not that good at all. Also
because, I mean, it's just their business model. They're
designed to keep you there for as long as
possible, and I mean, for the most part they
just don't work because You know, it's the way
that human relationships work is that And they are
more successful in the long term, the more time
you spend with the person you get eventually into
a romantic relationship with. And so it takes time
to build. It's, I mean, the sort of mentality
that we have nowadays of serial dating and, OK,
I don't know that person at all. I just
know how she looks. And the little information that
she put on Tinder or another app, and I'm
going to, and I'm going on a date with
her and now I'm very impatient because I really
want to know if I want, if there's going
to be something here or not. I mean, that
just doesn't work. I mean, people, people traditionally, and
it makes lots of sense. THE people they used
to date with people from their school, from their
university, from their workplace, from their local community, because
those are the ones that we tend to form
long term relationships with or we've been interacting with
for a long time before we get into a
romantic relationship with them. And I mean these kinds
of arrangements. It doesn't seem to me that they
work most of the time. So,
so do you think that, um, I mean, you're
saying that, you know, the, the loss of kind
of public spaces to connect? That's an interesting point.
And I think that's actually probably why, um, religious
communities are doing relatively well when it comes to
partnering and stuff is because there is a, a
a public space. I mean, it's not really pop,
but you know what I mean, like, they can
meet each other and There's that kind of more
traditional dating experience rather than the, the hinge date
or whatever, Tinder, whatever. But, um, do you think
that that the loss of public relationships is like
a cyclical issue with dating, where less people are
going to go out and put themselves out there
or meet people, because they also have in their
hand a way to scroll and find um potential
suitable. And the reason why I asked that is
because when I was single, um, I rarely use
dating apps. I probably use dating apps for 2
weeks my entire life. Uh, I didn't meet my
fiance via dating app. We actually met in the
gym. And I, as a single person, I actually
found no issue finding group events. There was a
running clubs, so many running clubs. I hate running.
I didn't, I didn't do it. But there were
lots of running clubs. There were walking clubs. There
was. Every Friday there was an event, and I
mean this is citywide, and I don't live in
New York City, but I do live in a
mid-sized city, um, and it was like every Friday
we had, um, uh, grass volleyball, and there was
like flag football and there was, um, ultimate frisbee,
and then people were constantly setting up hiking groups.
I was on Meetup a lot. There are tons
of groups on Meetup for like, if you're interested
in AI. I did some AI stuff, all these
things, uh, um. You know, I joined another group
where I learned how to house hack, stuff like
that. So I'm like, well, I, do you think
that there's some kind of like a self-perpetuating problem
here where I agree we are losing kind of
like the community public sphere, but at the same
time, because we are given these apps, there's not
as much motivation to go out to do it.
Yeah, I mean, probably that makes perfect sense to
me, and I, and I think that also, I
mean, the more time you spend indoors just scrolling
through your, uh, I don't know, your social media
and things like that and just trying to rely
on, oh yes, someday I will eventually find the
guy. Or the girl on the dating app, I
mean, I, I think that further reinforces you being
more and more and more indoors because you, I
mean, at a certain point you probably people don't
even think anymore that it's worth just going outside
and trying to meet new people. Also because again
there's not lots of public, proper public spaces to.
That and another important thing here has to do
with whether you can go to a public space
and not spend money because I mean again the
economic aspect of things are you could go to
a cafe, you could go to a restaurant, you
could go to the shopping or to the the
shopping mall or whatever, but I mean those are
all spaces where you have to spend money and
you know nowadays people are so. Thin when it
comes to money. I mean, it's so hard for
them that, oh, OK, so if I now go
with my friends to the cafe to try to
meet a new girl that they might introduce me
to, yeah, I, I go there, but I have
to spend money on beer or coffee or whatever,
and I don't really have that money or I,
I'm barely making it through the month, so you
know. And these things all intersect with one another.
I mean, I mentioned these factors, but it's not
that they are completely independent from one another. So,
but, but again, I mean, again, I just mentioned
all of this to say that and because we
were talking about sex work, that I mean, it,
it seems really hard to me to make a
proper evidence-based case that Sex work is really one
major factor or the main factor, as some people
argue that has impacted romantic relationships in a negative
way.
But if, if dating apps are, do you Could
you make the argument that pornography is also, I
mean, dating apps aren't exactly like pornography, but they
are somewhat similar in that you are looking at
the perfect version or the preferred version from home
with no incentive to go out and meet anyone
or do anything. And dating apps do have a
psychological impact. We did this just discussed that. If
that's the case, then how could pornography not do
the same or similar?
Yeah, I mean, I mean, again, maybe it's just
that uh from what I know with conversations again
that I have on the show with neuroscientists, I
mean, the, the best. Ones I've had on the
show are with Nicole Prosi again, I've already mentioned
there and with Erik Sprinkel. We, we talked in
that conversation, we talk about the history of masturbation
and pornography, but we also talk about the psychological
impact that pornography might have on people and I
mean the The best data that we have tends
to point toward people who are the biggest porn
consumers are also the ones who tend to have
more sex. So that sort of idea
isn't that kind of an outlier though? Like, I
mean, are we looking at the top 1% in
that situation? Like, shouldn't we be looking at kind
of like a general, like the average person maybe?
I, I mean, I'm not completely sure about that,
and that's a, that's a great point, but I
mean, just to say that at least as far
as we know, I mean, the best knowledge I
know of out there points to the fact that
that sort of cliche idea that we have of,
oh yeah, the guys who consume more pornography are
the lonely ones. WHO live in their mother's basement
or wherever or they work, but they are constantly
indoors and they are serially masturbating to pornography or
whatever. I mean that's not really really very supported
by the evidence. I mean, what the evidence points
toward is really that. The people who like to
consume porn the most are the ones who have
high sex drives, and many of them, if not
most of them, not only consume porn but also
have sex with other people and with more people.
So, and it's the same actually for social media,
and this is something that many people are not
really aware of, but even in the Early 90s,
in the late 90s, early 2000s when there was
not even any social media, but people were, some
people were already worried that there were people out
there who supposedly were spending all their time on
the internet and stuff like that. But and back
then it was to have to get in touch
with other people. It was mostly forums and stuff
like that. But actually, for example, people who interact
with more people on the internet or who have,
for example, more friends on Facebook also tend to
be more sociable and they have bigger social networks
offline. So I mean that. There's also that, so
it's, it's not like, oh, OK, the people who
are less sociable are the ones who are all
the time on social media and they have all
of their friends online, but they don't have any
offline friends and stuff like that. And the same
for pornography. I mean the the. At least as
far as I know, I could be wrong, but,
uh, I mean, you, I mean, you've inspired me
to look into it a little bit more because
I'm very curious, and I want to see, um,
I want to check the two individuals that you
mentioned that you have videos on because that's, that's
very interesting. I want to see what their, what
their studies say. So thank you for bringing that
up.
Yeah, so look, we're, we're almost reaching our time
limits here. So do you think that there's anything
about sex work that it would be Worth talking
about that we haven't touched on really, or
I think we covered some main topics. And I
think what was really cool about our conversation was
that we also touched on a lot of things
that it kind of like, almost tangentially was related
to, which is, which is what I said in
the beginning of this video is that it's actually
a lot more um integrated, I guess, in our
society than I think a lot of people are
aware of. And that's why I think these conversations
are really important. Um, SO I'm, I'm, I don't
think there's anything else. Is there anything you'd like
to discuss in addition?
No, I don't think so. I, I, I mean,
I, I, I think that the only thing that,
but, but I'm not sure if there's any other
points that you would have to bring to the
table, but I was just wondering, since you're a
lawyer and you are really into how law works
and all of that, do you have any particular
perspective? From a lawyer's point of view when it
comes to full criminalization, partial criminalization, legalization, and decriminalization
of sex work, I mean, do, do you, because
I, I was wondering, I'm not a lawyer, so
I have a perspective on that, but I was
wondering if you from a legal perspective would have
something particular to to add to that.
You know, I think my big thing from a
legal perspective, and I kind of said this earlier,
is the overinclusivity and underinclusivity of laws. I just
think that when determining whether we want to make
laws about sex work, we really need to take
into consideration, um, who it includes, who it doesn't
include, who it might accidentally include or not include,
and actually have sure definitions of this kind of
stuff, because it is, um, once you implement these
laws, the theory is always great. But then once
it's implemented, it usually turns out to be something
very different than what is imagined. And so, I
think that we just have to make sure when
debating these laws, that, you know, we actually consider
the externalities that may come along with um certain
laws, whether the law is legalizing it or that
law is making it criminal, right? I also think
that what needs to be taken. Consideration. And this
is just, it's kind of from my legal perspective,
but again, it's um the overall externalities of laws
or the lack of laws. And we've talked about
this ad nauseam at this point, but it's like,
who else is being impacted by these things? And
what, how are we going to weigh what is
good and what is bad, or what is better,
what is worse, so.
Yeah, OK, so look, let's perhaps wrap up our
conversation. I mean, we could be here for another
2 or 3 hours because this is, uh, like
an endless, uh, topic that we can tackle. So,
but, uh, look, apart from your YouTube channel, which
I, uh, by the way, later on we'll send
you a link to add you as a collaborator
there at uh on our interview. Uh, APART from
your YouTube channel, where can people find you on
the internet?
Yeah, so, uh, they can also find me on
Instagram. It's crafty Thinking, and I also have a
sub stack and then Facebook as well.
OK, great, I will let them,
oh sorry, crafty thinking with a K like my
name, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, it will be in
the description. I will have all of that there.
So look, Carolyn, it's been really great to talk
with you. It's been a fascinating conversation, and I,
if you're open to it, maybe we can have
another one in the future.
Yeah, definitely. I thoroughly enjoyed this conversation. It, it
really got me thinking, and it was kind of
fun to, you know, go back and forth and
really dive into some of these topics and consider
things that I hadn't previously thought of. So, and
you asked great questions, so.
Hi guys, thank you for watching this interview until
the end. If you liked it, please share it,
leave a like and hit the subscription button. The
show is brought to you by Enlights Learning and
Development done differently. Check their website at enlights.com and
also please consider supporting the show on Patreon or
PayPal. I would also like to give a huge
thank you to my main patrons and PayPal supporters,
Perergo Larsson, Jerry Muller, Frederick Sundo, Bernard Seyaz Olaf,
Alex, Adam Cassel, Matthew Whittingberrd, Arnaud Wolff, Tim Hollis,
Eric Elena, John Connors, Philip Forst Connolly. Then Dmitri
Robert Windegerru Inai Zu Mark Nevs, Colin Holbrookfield, Governor,
Michel Stormir, Samuel Andrea, Francis Forti Agnun, Svergoo, and
Hal Herzognon, Michel Jonathan Labran, John Yardston, and Samuel
Curric Hines, Mark Smith, John Ware, Tom Hammel, Sardusran,
David Sloan Wilson, Yasilla Dezaraujo Romain Roach, Diego Londono
Correa. Yannik Punteran Ruzmani, Charlotte Blis Nico Barbaro, Adam
Hunt, Pavlostazevski, Alekbaka Madison, Gary G. Alman, Semov, Zal
Adrian Yei Poltontin, John Barboza, Julian Price, Edward Hall,
Edin Bronner, Douglas Fry, Franco Bartolotti, Gabriel Pancortez or
Suliliski, Scott Zachary Fish, Tim Duffy, Sony Smith, and
Wiseman. Daniel Friedman, William Buckner, Paul Georg Jarno, Luke
Lovai, Georgios Theophannus, Chris Williamson, Peter Wolozin, David Williams,
Dio Costa, Anton Ericsson, Charles Murray, Alex Shaw, Marie
Martinez, Coralli Chevalier, Bangalore atheists, Larry D. Lee Jr.
Old Eringbon. Esterri, Michael Bailey, then Spurber, Robert Grassy,
Zigoren, Jeff McMahon, Jake Zul, Barnabas Raddix, Mark Kempel,
Thomas Dovner, Luke Neeson, Chris Story, Kimberly Johnson, Benjamin
Gelbert, Jessica Nowicki, Linda Brendan, Nicholas Carlson, Ismael Bensleyman.
George Ekoriati, Valentine Steinmann, Per Crawley, Kate Van Goler,
Alexander Obert, Liam Dunaway, BR, Massoud Ali Mohammadi, Perpendicular,
Jannes Hetner, Ursula Guinov, Gregory Hastings, David Pinsov, Sean
Nelson, Mike Levin, and Jos Necht. A special thanks
to my producers Iar Webb, Jim Frank, Lucas Stink,
Tom Vanneden, Bernardine Curtis Dixon, Benedict Mueller, Thomas Trumbull,
Catherine and Patrick Tobin, John Carlo Montenegro, Al Nick
Cortiz, and Nick Golden, and to my executive producers,
Matthew Lavender, Sergio Quadrian, Bogdan Kaniz and Rosie. Thank
you for all.